oh hi you know we're big fans of retro
games here at game life and you know
there's just something about those giant
pixels and simple 2d gameplay that you
don't get with the games of today that's
why we are reviewing retro game
challenge it's a new game for the
nintendo DS that takes us back to a more
innocent time than 1980s in retro game
challenge an evil game master has sent
you back in time and turned you into a
child to get back to the future you have
to beat challenges in a variety of
different retro games these aren't just
old games in a new package they are
brand new games designed to mimic and
parody the classics of old take robot
ninja haggle man one of the games you'll
be playing now it's graphics and
gameplay are straight out of making 85
what's clever about retro game challenge
is that it's not just about Oh beat this
level or beat that level it gives you a
series of challenges to complete like
kill two enemies at once or clear level
3 without using your ninja stars the
games that make up this fake collection
or complex and varied there's shooters
there's racing games there's even an RPG
this this keeps things exciting the
progression cleverly mirrors how the
game industry developed over time the
graphics and gameplay become more
complex in each successive game even
once you finish the little challenges
the games themselves are still fun to
play well some of them are the shooters
like star prints and cosmic gate are
engaging and the RPG guardia quest is
surprisingly big too bad the driving
game rally King is terrible it's a bad
game made by bad people what's worse
they make you play it twice yeah I get
it it's a parody of how some old game
sequels were just the same game
repackaged it doesn't matter it's still
hateful luckily in these cases a big
part of retro game challenge is the fact
that you can cheat your way through the
games just like back in the day every so
often you'll find
new issue of game fan magazine which you
can read through to find tips on the
games cheat codes and information on the
games you're going to play next and it's
the little touches like this that take
retro game challenge from being a
novelty to a true classic in its own
right we give it an 8 out of 10